we have a special what to watch today
we've been talking about it all morning
long this is a first on CBS mornings we
are talking with Michael block the club
pro from Southern California who gives
golf lessons at Arroyo Trabuco golf club
that is a public course in Mission Viejo
Orange County it charges 125 dollars for
a 45 minute lesson
exactly yeah
that was yesterday's fight that was
yesterday
yesterday's price because block stole
everyone's attention at the PGA
Championship this weekend Michael block
we are so honored you are joining us
right now good morning congratulations
brother Standing Ovation
all right Michael
thank you so much so so let me ask you
right off the bat I mean you got very
emotional when you were talking about
this big moment um you said it doesn't
get any better than this tell me what
it's like to make History Michael
I never thought it would happen to me to
be honest you know like you said I'm
just a club professional from a public
golf course in Orange County California
and all of a sudden within a couple
rounds of 70s here at Oak Hill my life's
changed quite a bit and I'm still I'm
sitting here with you this morning so
yeah it's uh it's very surreal right now
and I'm just I'm trying to enjoy it as
much as possible
Michael tell us what's going on in the
video for non-golfers because you shoot
it's 151 yards from the pin uh the shot
is On Target looks like it's going to be
close gonna land on the green and then
there's a cutaway and it doesn't even
seem like it hits the pin it seems like
it just goes right in the hole
that's exactly right yeah it was a seven
iron flight it is a pretty good win into
us I I was paired with Rory McIlroy you
know one of one of my idols and uh I was
doing okay I just you know I was too
over at that point I was trying to get
back to even par I hit the seven I
couldn't see it go in the hole and all
of a sudden Rory's walking away and he
turns around and he has his arms open
and he's gonna give me a big hug and I'm
like I couldn't figure out why he's
giving me a hug if I just hit it close I
didn't think it went in the hole but the
crowd was going you know nuts and uh and
he comes up and he goes and Roy's like
it went in the hole and uh I'm just like
you got to be kidding me right now I
couldn't even believe it you might have
seen it on TV I couldn't believe it that
it actually went on the whole under that
moment in time uh yeah it was very very
cool
you said the crowd was going nuts and
speaking of going nuts uh there's a
video that your son recorded of your
Club losing their mind what was it like
to see that type of support and then
your son say this is the greatest moment
of my life yeah how old is your son
Michael how old is he
yeah
that was Dylan he just turned 18. uh he
also works both my boys work there at
the club uh they work outside service
every Sunday morning uh so they went
there I didn't know there was a watch
party going on there at O'Neill's uh
that was pretty darn cool and when I saw
that video last night it definitely
brought tears to my eyes and I've cried
more uh in the last couple days than
I've ever cried in my life so it's a
very meaningful event
I I would cry too because number one
your sons are proud of you you've got to
be proud of yourself and everybody's
cheering for you because what we hear on
the streets is you're a really nice guy
were you were you nervous yesterday
clearly you're good at what you do but
you're playing with some of the best of
the best as you're as you're starting
the game were you even nervous you'd
think I'm just gonna do me
that's that was the mantra for the whole
week was just to be myself
um I've tried in in past events to try
to be a tour pro which I'm not uh I was
just the the club pro normal guy out
there having a good time uh with my
caddy John and and all the other Pros
there and here at Oak Hill were
absolutely uh fantastic to me and along
you know obviously the Rochester crowds
in here in New York were absolutely
behind me 100 and uh it was the thrill
of my life now you've gotten you know
now you've been invited to continue
going on with the PGA do you feel
pressure pressure on yourself
uh
yeah maybe a little I mean I'm just
going to try to keep doing the same
thing you know I was lucky enough to get
invited this week now I'm heading
straight to uh Fort Worth for the
Charles Schwab challenge at the colonial
uh which is really really cool and I so
appreciate the invitation and then the
RBC Canadian open uh in June so the what
what this opportunity from you know
obviously the PGA of America which I'm a
member of uh and you know the 29 000
members across the country of course in
the 19 other guys that were here with me
and we were we're a team and it's called
the corbage you know Financial team and
we all came here together uh rooting
each other on and I was lucky make the
cut
Big Mike we appreciate you thank you so
much congratulations good luck moving
forward Big Mike
we'll be right back